hi I'm Anna I've been a offline for two
hours now and I uh
No
you're okay I'm addicted to the Internet
and it's not the whole like I can learn
about anything I want to with this
limitless source of knowledge Internet
it's the whole social networking
cyberstalking
over all wasted time I feel like all my
good habits like reading playing guitar
meditating
they've all been replaced with internet
surfing and I hate that I waste all this
time essentially bullshitting around but
I am the only one to blame it's not like
there's a demon in my computer calling
out to me instead of doing productive
things to improve myself as a person I
spend hours upon hours cyber stalking oh
my god she can mix pregnancy look sexy
good for you Megan Fox good for you you
know I tell myself to be disciplined and
to limit my time on the Internet and
it's a losing battle beat me
you can do it resist resist my child
but in the end I guess you can't blame
the gun
you gotta blame the person pulling the
trigger back and ever bitch stay awesome
Gotham
I'm a demon and today I want to eat the
best she's my own children or suck the
souls but people the acting process
welcome come to me come inside of me no
I cannot say that I cannot say come
inside of me what the fuck was I
thinking